hi my name is avinash and welcome to the
web analytics course um we're very
excited to cover some of the basics when
it comes to web analytics and the very
first one
perhaps is why do you need to do
wireless if you're doing anything on the
web
for the longest amount of time we have
made very
faith-based decisions when it comes to
our marketing our customer service our
advertising and other kinds of
activities that companies do and a lot
of it was dictated by the fact that we
didn't actually have access to a lot of
data
it was or it was very difficult to get
data but one of the coolest things about
the web is that you actually have access
to near infinite amounts of data
usually not for a lot and
so one of the reasons that you want to
use web analytics for is that
the simple act of of adding a tag to
your website allows you to have access
to an enormous amount of consumer
behavior when it comes to your digital
existence
that means that you get a really deep
understanding of what is working what is
not working what do consumers like what
don't they like where do they come from
where do they not come from and other
kinds of things and it allows your
company to make very smart decisions for
example if somebody walks into a chevy
dealership
here in santa cruz you probably have
very little idea about what caused that
person to come to the chevy dealership
but if somebody lands on chevy.com on
the other hand
they bring with them a lot of trace of
what caused them to come and engage with
you
for example they might have searched on
google for a particular keyword and now
you have access to that insight or they
might have come in response to
television commercial that you ran and
visited your website and you have access
to that so a lot of this is
a really great way to understand
effectiveness of how you spend your
money which in turn helps you
do very smart things when it comes to
your consumers
not only that but it also opens the mind
of your organization much wider maybe
you believe that the only thing you can
do on the chevy website is give
information that drives people to the
dealer but in reality people who will
engage with you online are going to be
there not only to
go figure out where the nearest dealer
is but they could be existing customers
looking for help or it could be car
enthusiasts who want to
customize their cars and trick them out
is play around
for and configure a card they might want
to buy six nine months from now or they
might just be people who want to
understand a lot more about chevrolet's
philanthropic efforts and at the moment
all of these things are very difficult
to be met in an offline world but with
online you can and that's where web
analytics plays a really key role
helping you understand why people come
to your website once they are there what
is it that they do and at the end of it
do they leave happy and did you make
money both of those questions get
answered very quickly
so now that you're very excited about
web analytics let me formally define
what web analytics actually is
and in my books the way that i have
defined web analytics is it's the
analysis of qualitative and quantitative
data about your website and your
competition to drive continuous
improvement about your digital presence
your customer needs and prospects which
translates into great and fabulous
desired outcomes both online and offline
for your business and it's more of a
formal definition of web analytics and
let me let me sort of cover a couple of
these pieces that are really really
important and the very first one is very
often web analytics is mistakenly
believed to be just the art of logging
into google analytics or adobe web
trends or ibm and analyzing all the
quantitative data you have related to
the clicks
and that is indeed a big component of
robotics is all about but it's also
about answering the question about why
people do what they do and that's where
sort of qualitative analysis around
surveys and usability tests and those
things come into equation one of the
cool things about the web is not only
can you analyze your own performance we
can actually analyze how your
competitors are doing which is very very
cool you there are paid tools that you
can use there are
free tools you can use but if you're
competing with somebody on the web you
can actually go get their data and you
can go understand how they are
successful or not and learn lessons from
what they are doing and go figure out
how to change your strategy in turn
it's also very important to understand
that
you can serve the needs of people who
want to buy from you right away or
donate money from you right away but
also people who are in the process of
just considering and that's the
difference between kind of people are
very close to becoming customers versus
people who are going to be prospects
it's going to take them a while to get
converted
and the last thing of course is all
about understanding that web analytics
does not simply affect what you do on
the web on mobile phones tablets or
desktop and laptops but actually what
happens to your offline existence if you
have a call center that will be
including web analytics if you have an
actual supermarket store or dealership
those things would be included so web
analytics at it at its holistic level
is the art and science of qualitative
quantitative analysis of your data and
your competition's data in order to
drive improvements to the consumer
experience online and to drive business
outcomes online and offline and that's
what makes it so very exciting
perhaps what is most exciting about web
analytics is how incredibly easy it is
for you to get into it that's that's the
that's probably my favorite part um
because if i just reflect back a few
years in my career i and and let's say i
have a website that i wanted to analyze
i would easily have to pay anywhere
between 50 000 to 5 million
in order to get a tool that would allow
me to analyze behavior people on the
website but what is really cool now is
that with tools like google analytics
which is free or
some other
log file analyzers which are free
it is actually really easy to get access
to data or you can get paid solutions
from ibm or adobe which are not
outrageously expensive but they just
cost some money regardless of the choice
that you make between free and paid you
actually can get access to data for
extremely cheap or for free so the one
cool thing to understand that there
isn't a barrier between you and becoming
smart because access to data is free
the journey to get better at analyzing
data of course takes a lifetime but it's
an easy place to start it doesn't cost a
lot of money if you don't have a lot of
money just remember web analytics is
going to help make your digital business
more profitable and your customers happy
it's easy to get started so go do it
hi welcome back to the web analytics
foundations course uh in this video
we're going to cover
uh one of my favorite sort of critical
absolutely amazing part of webinatix i
call it webmatics 2.0 it's a very key
concept if you want to do anything with
data on the web
one of the coolest things about
having to do analytics on the web is
that the data is mostly available for
free or for very cheap
in fact as we've covered in course
number one if you actually simply add a
javascript tag with six lines of code on
your website you get access to like a
hundred reports
with tons of power to do all kinds of
analysis on the clicks that people are
making on your website it is really
really cool it works for your desktop
website it works for your mobile website
you have access to a ton of click
behavior data
the challenge with the click behavior
data is while there is a lot of it and
there are a lot of really cool things in
it
for the most part it only answers the
question what
what happened
looking back
so you'll be able to answer questions
like what were the top 10 pages seen on
my website what were the top 10 products
that we were sold what were the programs
for which we got donations what pdfs
were downloaded what places did people
come from a lot of what
questions
but as you begin to dive into this data
one of the things that you'll find
is that it is very difficult to
understand
why
people do what they do on your website
that's the key part while we have access
to all of this data
we don't know why people behave the way
that they do for example you can see
what the top 10 pages are on your
website
but should they have been the top 10
pages on your website what were the most
important pages your
visitors could not find that should be
in the top 10 and how do you figure that
answer out
and that's when we reach the limitations
of click behavior
but the cool thing is we do have access
to many different ways
of answering many different questions
for behavior on our websites
i call this concept web analytics 2.0
and it's the it's a cluster of five
types of analysis that you'll do
that'll help you get a complete picture
of what's going on when it comes to your
digital presence
the very first question of course is the
what and that's all the click stream
analysis that you will be doing it'll
help you understand
what happened even with the six lines of
javascript code you'll get 80 of what
you need you do a little bit more work
you get the rest of the 20 what you need
the next question that you would want to
answer is what i call the how much not
only what happened but how much and this
is where we go and implement special
code or tracking that allows us to track
our e-commerce conversions or track the
micro conversions of consumer behavior
on your website so
what happened and how much was the
outcome of it on our business and that's
the question we're trying to answer
there and the third question that we'll
answer is the why and there are two
strategies that we can use one of the
most common strategies we'll use is to
actually collect voice of the customer
we do this using surveys that are easy
to implement on our website we use it we
do this using
usability studies we can do online or
offline or other ways of analyzing
consumer behavior one of my favorite
ways is to simply ask people why are you
here were you able to complete your task
yes or no it's a rich mind of why
information once you analyze the what
and the why it becomes easy to do
another wonderful thing which is to
leverage experimentation and testing to
figure out why people behave this way or
that way should we have
can we improve the performance of our
website if our website looked like had a
big box in the middle a sidebar
three small boxes at the bottom and a
lot of text is that a better way to get
people to what they want or the entire
website should be replaced with a photo
of an apple
which one is better
and you really don't know which one and
why
what kind of outcome you will cause on
your website and that's where a b
testing and multivariate testing plays a
very important and key role
and the last question that you will
answer is the what else and that's when
sort of you go beyond the limitation in
the bounds of your own business and your
own website and go look at your direct
competitors or adjacent competitors and
try and figure out what is working for
them and what is not working for them
so these are like the four questions
that you'll ask the what the how much
the why the what else and you'll answer
these four questions using
five different strategies click stream
analysis multiple outcome analysis
experimentation and testing voice of the
customer and competitive intelligence
and it leads to what i call the nirvana
state of finding the kind of insights
that give you a 360 degree view of the
performance of your website in context
of what customers were looking for and
allow you to figure out even more ways
of delivering happiness to your
customers and having higher revenue in
this combination
i call this entire concept multiplicity
the art and science of doing many things
well at one time rather than just
getting trapped in a silo that's the
world of web analytics and the very very
cool thing is when you go out and
execute your multiplicity strategy you
have tools available paid and free
all kinds in order to do much more
insightful analysis you can use google
analytics or adobe or web trends to do
click stream and outcomes analysis
you can use
tools like the website optimizer visual
website optimizer optimost and others to
do experimentation and testing if you
want to do voice of the customers there
are free survey solutions like q and
qual ru or you can use other longer more
paid versions of surveys from
answers.com for c or other strategies
and finally for competitive intelligence
you have access from search engines you
have access from competitive
intelligence tools like compete and
similar web all of these will help you
understand how your competitors are
behaving well but these help you
identify really robust insights to take
actions both smarter and faster than
your competitors in order to have a very
successful business
the challenge that you will face
is should we do all of this at one time
and you can't actually execute a
complete web analytics 2.0 strategy at
one time that wouldn't be wise
so i have created a very small matrix
that will help you understand in what
order you should execute and what
priority things should be in if you're a
small business start with click stream
move to outcomes
do experimentation and testing those are
my one two three for you why is the
customer competitive intelligence can
wait they can come later that's okay but
that's your one two three if you're a
medium-sized business
start with multiple outcomes analysis
absolutely critical for you to go from
medium to big
then do very amazing
click stream analysis and finally
experimentation testing and voice of the
customer and the very last thing you'll
do as a big huge gigantic business start
with voice of the customer move to
multiple outcomes then click stream
analysis and finally experimentation
testing and competitive intelligence so
now you have a very specific roadmap you
can use to go execute a web analytics
2.0 strategy it's not very difficult you
do it step by step and he helps you get
a much better understanding of how to
crush your competitors make your
customers happy and in exchange make a
lot of money good luck